e nicolas si je vous dis je te tiens tu
me tiens par la barbichette le premier
de nous deux qui rira quittera le
plateau ah bon la salle mardi perdu vous
avez perdu et bégonias place on va
poursuivre cette émission donc émission
spéciale 7,8 loisirs enregistré depuis
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines et nous recevons la directrice
du coup du pavé du canal bonjour bonjour
alors plateau ça peut vous servir oui
effectivement il faisait - reste était
en totale improvisation que la
thématique avec vous on va aborder les
lectures de l'été c'est ça voilà c'est
ça alors au mans avec le certains
ouvrages
qu'est ce que les yvelinois les saint
quentinois peuvent lire chez vous en
tout cas alors il ya peu de bd des
romans français des romans étrangers
donc je vais vous présenter tout d'abord
un roman israéliens ont assez peu de
littérature israélienne traduite en
français
c'est l'histoire de deux deux jeunes une
jeune femme qui est israélienne un jeune
homme qui est palestinien
ils se retrouvent à new york qu'ils y
font leurs études un soir ils se
croisent ils tombent follement amoureux
et dans cette parenthèse enchantée dans
un new york un peu qui fait un petit peu
oui un peu fantasmé on va dire il oublie
totalement le conflit
israélo-palestinien ils peuvent vivre
entièrement leur amour sans aucune
contrainte
jusqu'au jour où leur visa expiré il va
falloir qu'ils adaptent leur histoire ou
au conflit et une belle histoire d'amour
approprié pour l'été oui tout à fait
c'est très beau alors donc il ya
d'autres romans aussi alors un roman
dont le titre est assez évocateur pour
cet été s'appelle sonneurs se meurt
c'est une jeune fille très belle issue
d'une famille plutôt aisée ça se passe
au bord du lac léman
un jour elle disparaît et c'est son
frère qui va nous raconter la
disparition de cette soeur et des
conséquences sur la vie de la famille
des secrets
des trahisons et un frère qui évidemment
a beaucoup de mal à se remettre de cette
disparition est un peu plus triste que
le roman oui le précédent n'est pas très
gai non plus mais voilà je me laisse les
lecteurs découvrir on habitait il va se
reconvertir au téléachat il me fait
vraiment très bien effectivement michael
vous attendez pas à voir des films de
retour alors pauline amis et de votre
troisième roman michael va nous le
montrer c'est un roman américain oui
tout à fait un roman de grands espaces
l'histoire de deux soeurs après une
catastrophe qui mènent les états unis à
une panne d'électricité générale elles
vivent au fond de la forêt dans une
maison toutes les deux une et passionnée
de danse elle va danser jusqu'à jusqu'à
ce qu'elle n'est plus de piles dans son
transistor et mais elle va continuer à
écouter la musique qu'elle a dans la
tête et s'entraîner et la seconde soeur
elle était destinée à de grandes études
donc elle va se cultiver le plus
possible en lisant tous les livres cas
dans la maison et ça va se terminer par
la lecture des encyclopédies qu'il y
reste et on va suivre leur destin
évidemment il elles vont rencontrer des
gens ça va plus ou moins bien se passer
c'est un beau portrait de femme et un
beau un beau roman sur la femme un peu
poétique aussi avec oui alors deux
autres romans et après je vais vous
demander vos avis vos romans préférés
parmi la présentation que nous a fait
paulina miettes alors le quatrième roman
est un roman français n'est d'aucune
femme de franck bouyer
c'est un roman plus récent qui a reçu le
prix des libraires
c'est encore un beau portrait de femme
on suit le destin de rose
en fait on découvre ses carnets au début
du roman cette jeune femme a été vendu
en tout cas employé par un noble
elle est issue d'une famille de paysans
qui avait plus de moyens pour subvenir à
leurs besoins donc elle est employée
pour être bonne à tout faire assez vite
son rôle septembre on va dire voilà on
suit son histoire à travers ses carnets
n'est d'aucune femmes c'est ça implique
la naissance d'un enfant
on suit aussi le destin de cet enfant
c'est un très beau roman c'est une
personnalité très forte une femme assez
impressionnante d'accord donc là aussi
encore quelque chose
focalisé sur une personne plutôt oui
très long
tout à fait et le dernier alors le
dernier c'est une bd pour changer un
petit peu ce qu'on peut aussi lire des
bd sur la plage donc mezine grace
c'est une bd française qu'en format un
peu comme x c'est un premier tome on est
en 2035 huit ans après une catastrophe
nucléaire aux états unis les etats unis
sont réduits à une bande qui s'étend de
new york est la californie et sur ce
territoire
chacun essaye de survivre et on suit le
destin d'un an père et de sa fille qui
s'appelle joyce qui est une enfant de
l'hiver nucléaire
elle a des quelques particularités c'est
pas une enfant normale et voilà il faut
qu'il arrive à préserver ce hachis tout
en essayant d'avoir une vie à peu près
normale
alors là on s'éloigne un peu de du coup
de lime on n'est plus dans l'imaginaire
on s'éloigne de la réalité c'est plus de
la fiction
oui oui voilà c'est un peu plus
fantastique oui alors est-ce que vous
avez une préférence parmi les livres que
donc nous vous pouvez retrouver vos
téléspectateurs aux pavés du canal
marylène or moi vous aimez vous savez
j'aime bien quand on parle des femmes
n'est donc qu'une femme samedi bien
banon sous la même étoile me tente bien
un peu de romantisme de revendre été
pour cet été 2010 9 aurélie mois semaine
rien que pour le titre pour l'ol et
hélas à fond dans les théories mélanie
moi j'ai cru entendre parler de danse
donc mon coeur va aller vers la danse
nicolas gaitan compris le roman
américain et pour vous michael ce que
j'ai dans ma main justement maasing
l'oreille ce salaire très science
fiction mikaël joannides rhône pour la
plage cet été je pense